I'm in the United States especially and
in the West generally we have a model of
self where the self is kind of like an
avocado right and we have a pit inside
of us the pit is ourselves our essence
our identity it is the thing to which we
must above all be true and of course
very importantly we see that pit is
unique so that everything we do we want
to show to reflect that pitch reflect
that self and we want it to be unique in
Asia they people frequently have a flexi
self so it's a different kind of self it
is a self that's oriented more to duty
than to rights for instance and and very
importantly it it is not it does not
have have a cultural mandate to be
different and to be unique people in the
East are not all alike you know so if
you know if you looked at my family like
believe me every single person is very
very different and that is true of
course throughout Asia you know the
difference is not you know how different
are we from each other the difference is
how much significance do we attach to
that difference in other words do we
think it's very important to
differentiate ourselves from others so
if you ask care of other individuals of
course they're individuals you know are
they different of course they are
different but the course for them it's
like all of course I'm different why
would I make a big deal of a patent
right and they think it is very peculiar
that in the West that we feel that we
must you know differentiate ourselves
from others endlessly so one of the ways
that we do that of course is the choice
you know choice in the West is very very
important everyone is always making
choices and honestly a lot of those
choices make us a little anxious if you
do a study where you are just sitting in
an empty room and you're making a choice
and you come from more individualistic
culture you actually show signs of a
little anxiety you know every little
choice that you make even in private
because it's it's defining if you want
you who you are it's a little loaded
they feel like they just choose when
they migos choice is that it doesn't
this overlay and that's one of the
reasons they feel that actually we are
less less free than they are you know so
they think that we are the ones were
kind of in this prison where a you know
like I say every moment we must define
ourselves well isn't that awful right
and you know of course the way the way
that we live we feel that you know we
want to be freely electing to live the
way that we live right and so even when
we're doing things like taking care of
the elderly for example you know we want
to feel that we that is an extension of
our great love and the the nature of our
being to be able to take care of the
elderly well you know the other day I
was having dinner with somebody said you
know I just don't feel that and it's
just it's just very very hard you know
so somebody from a more flexi self or
interdependent culture would say you
know it's just your duty you know and so
for them it's like you know they have
their elderly parent they just go take
care of the elderly parent because
that's their duty for them this is
really liberating you know you just go
do it and you don't expect there to you
know it's do expression or yourself you
know this is what people do from their
point of view we have made things very
very hard for ourselves to do mad that
you know that everything should be an
expression of our inner nature
[Music]
you